hello everybody hope they are good this
is not a Bitcoin daily update because
Bitcoin is barely moving and the price
action it's been horrible and really
boring we talked about this on Monday
with in our previous video and also in
the bit consume the update on Twitter
because basically at right at the start
of the week we had a bank holiday Day in
the US Labor Day on Monday
and the rest of the week we didn't
really have any major news announcements
so we were expecting to have a very
quiet week and so far we're having a
very boring week so
um I wanted to update you a bit about
the Alcon Market because I do think that
right now it's more productive to pay
attention and do some research to the to
some altcoins instead of trying to trade
this price action in Bitcoin that's
horrible they don't want to make any
money I mean if you've been trading from
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
and eventually in Bitcoin and welcome I
don't know how you've made any money
because I'm telling you it hardly moved
anything all right so
um me personally I've picked a couple of
trades in all coins this week they were
they went pretty well and what I'm doing
the most is doing some research trying
to choose up the portfolio that I want
to have in an export Market okay and of
course at what prices I can buy those
coins
so that's pretty much what I've been
doing this week that's it now this
altcoin market update I think it's quite
important
because
the same as the previous outcome market
update
um two months ago I told you guys I
think altcoins are looking quite heavy
quite a very I think I want to make some
new looks and that's when you know they
had some influencers on Twitter telling
you that we must have a new old season
and all of that and then all queens make
new lows
okay now do I think Vulcans are going to
make again new looks
I do think so okay I think altcoins are
gonna make new lows in the next three to
five months and in this video I'm going
to explain to you why I think so all
right so first of all we have to talk
about Bitcoin because when Bitcoin booms
the outcome Market dumpster okay follows
Bitcoin so
um Let me let me talk to you about the
weekly 50ma this level it's very
important for Bitcoin historically all
right so you can see how it's been
playing out all this time
and especially in the previous uh six
months all right you can see here the
e-axis resistance and then uh Bitcoin
don't quite happy then in may we tested
a support one two three four times and
then we saw a pump and now if you notice
we're testing our resistance here so
what do you think is going to happen
well I think that is very likely that if
we continue
being below this key level the 50 I mean
weekly time frame then it's like that we
doom again okay and where can we do well
the two levels that I see here in the
chart
are this liquidity pool over here
okay let me Mark it for you
so it will be hang on it will be
something like this all right that's
your liquidity pool um that goes to the
level of 21 100 you can say 22 000 boo
in my opinion even a bigger imbalance
right below it and it's this week over
here okay
that week over here
that's a problem for Bitcoin in my
opinion another thing that at least 50
of this week is gonna get filled okay
and that will take you around twenty
thousand seven hundred so do I think
Bitcoin is gonna go to twenty thousand
seven hundred
I do things okay again I don't know how
long it's going to take if I had to
guess it would be three to five months
but we'll see all right now if you
notice in this exact point
when Bitcoin was testing the weekly 15
minutes resistance Bitcoin boomed at
twenty percent now from this point from
the weekly 50ma the Uber testing a
support Bitcoin pumped also at twenty
percent all right so now the next
question is
if bit condoms from here from the weekly
50ma it's also gonna be at 20 percent
and that takes it to this week or to
this liquidity pool
also right let's say 18 then it's at 22
so yeah pretty much to this level okay I
don't know if it's gonna repeat this
button and we're gonna drop another
twenty percent like we did previously
but you know it's uh it's quite a
curious data there isn't it so that's
what I think I think Bitcoin is due to
drop towards this Zone again we might
consolidate here more I'm not telling
you so okay we might consider here and
then drop here
and this may take some months to develop
okay this move
but that's what I'm choosing to believe
okay I'm choosing to believe that
Bitcoin can drop again to this Zone and
in fact to me this is the most probable
scenario and again this is not Financial
advice
it's only my opinion I might be right
with this one I might be wrong we'll see
what happens time will tell so this is
the first chart that I wanted to go
through it's Bitcoin in higher time
frame because if Bitcoin drops the
alcohol Market drop and the Bitcoin
drops at 20 the alkaline Market doesn't
drop at 20 percent
it drops a lot more it might drop 35 40
45 right now I want to take you to the
next chart
dice debit condominance there is a chart
that I find quite useful
and and to be honest it helped us to to
not lose money I would say and let me
tell you what I think okay first of all
we've been inside this range brain size
range lows all right for two years now
if you remember in this point
I was telling you this time it looks
different it seems like we're gonna have
a Breakout and while I was telling you
that
many influencers here in on YouTube I
think and of course on Twitter they were
telling you well where are the rain size
we want to see a drop to the range
lowest as you wrote season by altcoins
and that's when I was telling you guys
this chart is everything but bullish it
looks really very the outcome Market is
looks very heavy and it's likely that we
see a breakout in a Bitcoin dominance
and then we also see new lows in
altcoins and that's what happened and my
conclusion was that this time looked
different because price was
consolidating here instead of spiking up
and dropping you can see all the time
that behavior okay so they indeed look
different and that's what happened now
the idea that I want to bring to you
is
what would happen to altcoins
if Bitcoin drops in the next three to
five months or whenever it drops to 20K
and the Bitcoin dominance
here I would have two options okay it
can drop with Bitcoin but it doesn't
matter that is still bad for altcoins
okay if any debits condominance goes
down
um boy if Bitcoin goes down too then
alquins are gonna go down too right but
we have that scenario
that both things go down and then
articles go down but now think for a
second what happens if Bitcoin goes down
but the Bitcoin dominance finds some
support in these two gr range in the
range size here okay what would happen
if Bitcoin goes down on the Bitcoin
dominance hold this on
well then all queens are gonna get so
wrecked
and when I say wrecked I mean like a 60
70 drop
very likely right so either way I think
that
you know whatever happens yeah it's
gonna be bad for alkins because I don't
see the scenario
um where Bitcoin can grow up from here
and the Bitcoin dominance can go down I
don't see that coming I mean could this
be a massive deviation
I don't know to me looks more like a
breaker than a retest of support to be
honest it's a 2dr cycle so the support
here should be quite important now right
so that's what I think I think that is
more likely that whatever happens
um again I'm I'm not a Bitcoin maxi
and I'm not against all coins in fact
you know for the past one month and a
half to two months pretty much the main
thing that I've been doing is
researching outcomes because I think the
articunes are gonna give us the the
biggest rewards in the next bull market
and I say this because this is what
happened in previous World Markets all
right so trust me I'm bullish in
outcomes in the long term I'm just not
bullish or I'm embarrassed in them in
the midterm that's all all right
um it's not necessarily A Bad Thing If
altcoins drop
as long as you are prepared for it but
anyway
that's what I think about the alcohol
Market I think it's likely that all
queens Get Wrecked still and they make
new lows at least most of them
all right
so that's what I wanted to say about the
Bitcoin dominance now if you go to any
altcoin chart and you go for example
let's go to evax and go to the Bitcoin
dump to the Bitcoin chart a bit compare
you can see
the the only thing that is doing is
making new lows constantly you know last
week we made a new lows
are in the in the Bitcoin pair
um and and you can check this with
pretty much every outcome go for example
to chain link
all right you can see here
I only see it on trend lower highs lower
lows
okay
that's all I see so you know is it
really it is the time to buy all coins
that's a question that I'm asking myself
um if I had to answer myself
I would say not yet
so my game plan is to still be a bit
more patient
way to see what happens in the next
three to five months or so so that would
take us to between December and January
um I believe that there is a chance that
alcorns uh continue going down okay so
that's everything really that I wanted
to say now if you go to the total free
and you compare this to the Bitcoin
chart no so how is it total free
Bitcoin
there you go
all right let me check this
these are the two levels what I would
consider by an altcoins
right so
these are the two levels and that is
basically suitable five
and civil 30.
I think that the difference here what
happens is when I beat what happens
first in the Bitcoin dominance all right
though
anyway if you see this what is downtrend
so far we're having broke this high so
this is still all over High okay
um this is the naturalness that we make
a new lower low
right so is Trend that's all I see I see
that we're listening are downtrend to be
honest with you guys so be careful get
ready what I'm pretty much doing now
it's doing a lot of research on all
queens trying to
think what portfolio I want to have for
the next full Market well category of
Falcons can explode in the next full
Market maybe gaming kind of be
artificial intelligence can it be
um if I again uh these are the type of
switching you have to ask yourself and
then choose the best all coins
the in each category okay so that's
pretty much what I'm doing of course
checking the team tokenomics market cap
all those things guys you know so I'll
probably update some more videos about
in the future so that's pretty much
everything that I wanted to say guys
just don't expect me to upload a video
soon
you know talking about my altcoin
portfolio that I'm gonna have in the
explore Market because I still haven't
decided that myself so don't expect a
video anytime soon I'm still doing my
research basically what I'm doing is you
know trying to understand what category
of alkins can explode in the next bull
market can it be gaming canopy
artificial intelligence Canadian defy
again what can it be and if so
so that's pretty much what I'm doing
looking at the team looking at economics
looking at the roadmap the partners
looking at I don't know the market cap
everything nice okay so don't expect it
anytime soon I might in the future
uh talk about some projects
on not paid sales of course just
outcomes that I find interesting enough
that I could buy for the next bull
market
um I want to sell your analysis with
with you I don't know if I'm gonna prove
that type of content probably yes uh
because I think that you guys would like
it so
um that's what I'm thinking in terms of
the helpful Market I think it's likely
that
they make new lows again I said that two
months ago when it happened when
everybody was calling for an old season
so
um I saved a lot of money there and now
I'm expecting
in the next again three to five months
Maybe new lows so thank you so much guys
for watching and I'll see you soon